philippine president ferdinand marcus jr
was done by his nickname pongpang won
the may election by a landslide while
calling for unity among filipinos duty
as president of the republic on monday
in his first state of the nation address
he was expected to lay out concrete
steps for how he would make good on what
his supporters say were his campaign
promises
the number one concern is the price of
rice so many people are going
the
hungry
did deliver on specifics marcus touched
on agriculture health care energy
education foreign policy and tax and
investment law reforms
agreement reform is not only about
acquisition but also about support
services and distribution
to assist this i intend to issue an
executive order to impose a one-year
moratorium on the payment of land
amortization and interest payments
corruption and human rights however were
nowhere in the speech
earlier in the day protesters gathered
to air grievances but authorities
prevented them from getting anywhere
near the house of representatives where
marcus delivered his address
protesters are demanding solutions to a
host of problems but the one issue that
they feel has been sidelined is human
rights there are unresolved human rights
issues dating from the 21-year
dictatorship of the president's father
ferdinand marcos senior all the way to
the recent administration of rodrigo
duterte
human rights activists say thousands
were victims of summary executions and
torture during the martial law period
from 1972 to the early 80s
and thousands of drug suspects were
killed in drug war operations in the
last six years under president duterte
he has to address the human rights
situation
it's a problem that the whole world
knows about so it can't
it can't have the philippine president
oblivious to the problem of human rights
in the philippines
but for many who voted for marcus the
past is the past
the son is not the father all i can say
is i believe in bong bong marcos
despite the difficult challenges and
intense criticism of the marxists there
is optimism
echoed by the president as he ended his
speech saying the state of the nation is
sound
barney below al jazeera manila